brian is with us in Fort Wayne Indiana
hey Brian how are you hi good afternoon
thanks for taking my call Dave certainly
how can I help sir well I took this
great municipal job about 16 years ago I
had a retirement fund that is been set
for the last 16 years in a guaranteed
fund was that or indifferent I was
guaranteed that I would get some sort of
retirement at the rule of 85 here in
Indiana and I don't know there's a part
of this that's called an annuity and you
are able to place part of that in
different sectors of the stock market
run and I have no idea I'm not a money
person I don't know what to do with that
well here's the good news it's not
rocket science it is going to require
that you learn some things so that
you're making good choices on your own
what I recommend is and what I
personally do with my 401k is I put my
mutual funds in or uh put my investments
inside of my 401k which is inside your
annuity in this case in four different
areas growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international now
growth and income is the more stable
boring category and sometimes that's
called large cap or blue chip does any
of that sound like one of your options I
think that is one of our options okay
then and I put some in that and I put a
fourth in that I put a fourth in growth
growth is called mid cap or growth or
sometimes just an S&P 500 index fund
would represent a growth fund something
along those lines and then aggressive
aggressive growth is is obviously small
aggressive companies their startup
companies they're the smaller companies
the more volatile sometimes those are
called emerging markets or small cap if
you see that small cap means
capitalization so capital small
capitalization means small company okay
and that's all right that's going to be
your more volatile it's it's big rates
of return but it's the biggest roller
coaster
of the ones the growth and incomes the
calmest of the four and then
international obviously means stocks in
companies outside the US and so
sometimes those are called a foreign
fund or it is a kissing cousin called a
global fund global would have some u.s.
in it but on the foreign as well a pure
foreign would have no u.s. in it so
that's the only difference there that's
the type of thing you're looking at is
you're going to spread it out across
different things if you got it all in
the boring then you're going to you're
going to be bored at retirement there
any money
if you got it all in the exciting you're
going to be scared to death all the time
you know and so I want a little thrill I
want a little Tabasco on my food but I
don't want to not be able to eat it you
know what I'm saying that so got ya a
little spice and that's all we're doing
here is we're mixing it up and having a
little of the calm and a little of the
wild and a little over-seasoned and so
that the word that investors use for
spreading your money around is called
the word is diversification but that's
all diversification means spread around
now one it would one of your yield
please be able to guide me a little bit
on this with somebody knows what yes he
has absolutely yeah they would know in
their heart you probably over the phone
would know because they're right there
in your community and they've looked at
the state plan 20,000 times over the
years and they'll be able to just go hey
here's what you got is what you got here
she got but here's the thing you can't
be an endorsed local provider of ours if
you don't have the heart of a teacher
and so in the last few minutes here on
the radio you've learned a couple of
little basic things from me maybe you
knew them before I don't know but you
learned some basic stuff I want you to
continue to learn a little bit more so
you're not doing something because Dave
Ramsey said or you're not even doing
something because that ELP said you're
doing something because you learned
enough to make the decision and then you
understand why we're suggesting
something so you already understood I
was suggesting four different things
why because spreading it out like that
gives you some safety and get it and
you're not too excited where you can't
breathe you know that kind of thing so
that that's what that diversification
thing means so you just got to learn
that from the ELP but just go to Dave
Ramsey comm and click on ELP and they'll
help you and let me send you a copy of
Chris Hogan's number one best
the book retire inspired and it's got a
bunch of really good information you can
begin to learn about this stuff again
I'm not trying to turn you into some
kind of PhD in economics with a pocket
protector nerd okay
but I do want you to understand where
your money's going because you're the
one that's responsible for it once I'm
done with the debt snowball now even
though I have my city accounts the
municipality accounts do I still want to
put fifteen into my sum sorry for myself
yeah yeah you want to put fifteen
percent into something now if you're
putting money into the city you can
deduct that amount from the fifteen
percent but I want you have some stuff
that's not at the city and so a good
Roth IRA and some good mutual funds as
well would be a way to do that so hold
on I'll have Kelly pick up and send you
a copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim
Oh